hi I'm Eric Voss and the Punisher on
Netflix has an official release date
November 17th and a new trailer filled
with more Metallica more darkness and
more Jon Bernthal grunts can add things
so let's quickly run through this and
point out some of the stuff you might
have missed cool let's get started
gentlemen I'm the only authority you
will need I point you shoot
did you kill the target okay this first
section gives us more context for the
black ops mission in Afghanistan that
Frank castle was part of that led to his
troubles back home we see Rollins again
the shadowy CIA figure who is apparently
running this operation and judging from
Cassel being covered in blood and taking
a swing at him I'm guessing this mission
went south and these men weren't given
the complete information on what the
mission was
then look closely at this shot of castle
firing out the door now I can't tell the
person who's firing at is an also armed
hostile insurgent or an unarmed civilian
fleen either way I have a feeling that
castle may have been ordered to do
something unethical and that's what he's
so pissed off about let's move on things
over there what we're doing is really
you do what you're supposed to do right
now the only person you're punishing is
yourself Frank Castle got something I
need to show
rest of the video files the US military
turns you over hitman Frank okay in this
next section it looks like Frank is
participating in some group therapy in a
church basement nice word play here with
the only person you are punishing is
your self line yeah it looks like the
Punisher will be dealing with those same
Catholic guilt and redemption themes
that another Marvel Netflix series
embraced where a devil of Hell's Kitchen
battled with his own inner Devils see I
can do it too we also see more of micro
the hacker / whistleblower character who
teams up with Frank to take down his
former superiors now in our last trailer
I pointed out the file name at the top
of the window these do by year
interrogation and a lot of you pointed
out to me that zoo by ear is actually
the name of a town in Iraq that's
correct but we find out in the next
section that applies to something
different let's move on I'm looking for
Frank Castle The Punisher I think you
know the bobwhite case
Kasich's the last witness we can either
clean this up or let them take us down
okay here again we see the department of
homeland security agent Dena Madani and
judging from her investigation board you
know the kind that investigators but
also conspiracy theorists have her case
focuses on the mission that Cassell was
a part of and now we see what Zoo by ear
refers to it's a named Ahmad sue by ear
so the zoo by ear interrogation
literally refers to probably the torture
of this guy Ahmad perhaps he uncovered
evidence of an assassination program
that Rollins is running illegally in
Afghanistan also notice how in this shot
Rollins now has this sick looking scar
next to his eye socket apparently had
that last trailer but it just zoomed in
so much I didn't notice now his
discolored I suggest that he lost vision
in that eye and I'm assuming he got this
injury from castle remember we saw him
punch him earlier that's actually looked
more closely at that hit whoa castle
punches freaking eye out does that
happen can people punch that hard
I guess Jon Bernthal can just been
lifted bro now the other mysterious shot
in this section is this sniper scope
point of view shot showing a carousel
now the entity makes it look like it's
in the same scene as castles memory of
his murdered family but look closely
that looks like a woman and her daughter
bloodied up and bound the carousel so
what the eff is going on here what why
would anyone want to do this considering
the murder of castles family was
probably a surprise assassination they
didn't see coming I don't think this is
that same event instead I think someone
is recreating the murder of castles
family with different people just to
mess with castles head it's very easy to
mess with and this sniper shot is from
his point of view this all could be
orchestrated by Billy Russo aka jigsaw
after all it is the kind of creepy death
trap move another jigsaw would pull
let's move on
[Music]
you have nothing but a war inside you
okay the music here in this trailer is
still Metallica's one it's just a
different part of the song actually we
went deep into that song steam attic and
acoustic parallels to the Punisher my
breakdown to last trailers to check that
out and Frank's voice over here they
killed my family to get to me is
interesting because it officially
changes the background of his family's
murder from being crime related to part
of this military government conspiracy
cover-up
remember in daredevil season two Castle
was under the assumption that Reyes is
war against drug gangs in connection
with the blacksmith's drug supply lines
were responsible for the violence that
took his family but here it seems that
this season of the Punisher is making
the cause even more personal for castle
in the section we also see more of this
car chase that we saw in the last
trailer but now we see you behind the
wheel of the pursuing car DHS agent
Deena Madani and we get an even closer
look of what happens to her in this next
section
[Music]
yikes okay this car accident mess Dina
up for a second she actually looked dead
which would be crazy to show the death
of a main character in the trailer but
no look closely that's her I definitely
blinking there it does seem like Castle
was the one to plow that truck into
Dina's car but the fact that he carries
her away from this accident scene
suggests that he doesn't want her to die
just to stop following them but you know
the punisher just has trouble using his
words another way to look at this is
perhaps someone else drove that truck
nearly killing Dina maybe if we're
getting too close to Rollins in her
investigation and castle was the right
guy in the right place at the right time
showed up to kill these other guys and
safer no no we'll see let's move on I
need to find these bastards I got a cure
so where does that end Frank what if
you're exposed in this section we see
the dependable Karen page trying to talk
down castle from his revenge quest I
really like her saying where does it end
because it's pretty much how the
punisher operates in the comics he
actually already avenged his family's
death way in the past the killers were
among his first victims when he started
being a vigilante but he is so broken
that the war never stops for him being
the Punisher is just his identity now
also when Castle is infiltrating this
building notice the security guards hat
and jacket and vole anvil corporation is
named the arms contractor that Billy
Russo aka jigsaw now works for which
could be his connection with Rollins and
the government let's move on these men
they decide with the tradition
the same thing that happens to new
opportunity
we could make that right
okay some more action in these shots
including a shootout with Deena and what
looks like some clothing manufacturing
warehouse notice those mannequins this
is an interesting location I'm wondering
who in Deena's investigation led her
here my theory is Madame Gao last time
we saw her was in the defenders in that
big underground fight at Midland Circle
as the building above caved in but we
didn't see her body so I'm guessing
she's still around
also in daredevil season two Matt found
Madame Gao in a laundromat type place so
I'm thinking it's possible that this
clothing warehouse could be another one
of Madame GAO's fronts perhaps she is an
informant on Dina's way to learning the
truth about the criminal underworld of
Hell's Kitchen the blacksmith and
perhaps any connections to Roland also
this upset woman appears to be micros
wife perhaps castle this season will
help repair micros family since you know
you cannot ever repair his own let's
move on to the final section
the world needs to see the truth
okay this trailer closes that with some
more intense action but then after the
title we get the release date November
17th so this is interesting for a few
reasons for one yes it does appear that
Netflix plan to release the Punisher
earlier than this in the month of
October but they might have pushed back
the release date because of mass
shootings being in the news Jason are
Moore who plays Curtis Hoyle apparently
liked a tweet where someone speculated
this now they've moved it to November
17th which yes is the same day justice
league is opening now a lot of fans
begin to speculate that this is an
aggressive move by Marvel to compete
with DC and Warner Brothers but I
honestly don't think that factored into
the decision that much yes there is some
healthy competition between these two
studios and that probably did factor
into them moving through a Ragnarok into
the same month that's Justice League but
on the Netflix side of things Netflix
just has a dense release calendar with
new series or movies dropping pretty
much every Friday and guys to be honest
a streaming service series release isn't
really much of a competitor with a huge
wide release of a film from a major
studio worldwide not everyone is at war
with each other just Frank Castle he's
at war with everything and himself
should the punisher have changed casas
family death backstory for a mob killing
two military assassination now if you
like this video you may be interested in
checking out a new series new rockstars
is launching called the need to know and
on next week's episode the need to know
is holding a costume contest on the show
we feature video reactions from our
friends and followers on Stardust and if
you post your reaction to your favorite
TV shows or films in your best Halloween
costume and tag us in that post we one
could feature you in our episode of the
need to know but to you will be entered
into our costume contest in the top
three will win cash prizes guys you got
to get on this it's a great opportunity
and by the way you can download the
Stardust app by clicking our download
link in the description below so check
out the need to know and comment on this
video any thoughts you have down below
and tweet your thoughts directly to me
at EA boss or for all the new rock stars
on Twitter at new rockstars for updates
under videos like and share this video
and subscribe to new rockstars for more
deep dives and all the Marvel stuff that
you love and if you really like our
videos you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our donors
especially Kenny Smith thanks for
watching bye